when working with probability density
functions a situation we found ourselves
in a lot is integrating and then
substituting in some values where the
values are quite messy so we just hand
over to a calculator to do all that
arithmetic and number country for us and
that's something we're pretty used to
but one of the things that comes up is
that often a calculator is not
sufficient technology to be able to come
up with the answers that we're looking
for and this is an example of that so I
want to walk you through what to do when
you encounter a question that requires
this this question starts off relatively
simply you've got a continuous random
variable and the probability density
function is given here so it's defined
in this way over this particular domain
and then the question is find the medium
this is the thing that we're being asked
to search for so I'm just going to
highlight that because it's important
now if we try to find the median number
one we're going to have to work out
what's the technique that I use for that
and then number two I'm gonna have to
use the appropriate technology to
actually locate the answer so how do I
find the median well since we know that
if you integrate a probability density
function over its entire domain that
should give you one
therefore if we're saying from you know
the beginning of the domain up to the
median the median we recall is the
middle score so if you go from the
bottom of your interval to the middle
then and you integrate the function you
should get half of the people and the
same is true if you started from the
median and then went to the end of your
data set so if I went from you know
instead of going from a to q2 if I went
from q2 to B where B was my endpoint I
should still get a half like I have here
and it just is up to me whether I want
to use the start point or the end point
and when I have a look at this it looks
to me that the start point being zero is
going to be more useful because when I
evaluate it in my integral my definite
integral it'll often end up being zero
so why not use that so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to take this idea over
here and I'm going to use it in this
particular situation so what are my a
and my q2 well a is zero q2 is my
unknown so it's just going to stay there
and then here comes my f of X it's three
over 13 x squared plus four I'm
integrating with respect to X and as we
were saying before
this should give us a half alright so
here's my trajectory I know where I'm
headed now and sort of my calculus in
brain kicks in let's start doing the
work in here so the three over thirteen
I'm going to factorize that out the
front so that I don't need to worry
about it in the process of integration
I'm going to write that DX is equal to
1/2
I noticed that I've got this 3 over 13
over here and then is half over here so
these are both constant coefficients so
I might it'll combine them while I'm at
it so what I'm gonna do is we're gonna
multiply both sides by 13 on 3 if I
multiply both sides by the reciprocal of
this it'll cancel this term there x 13
on 3 we'll just end up on the right-hand
side
and I might as well while I'm at it
actually perform the integration so x
squared it integrates up into X cubed on
3/4 integrates up into 4 X and then I
have my lower and my upper boundaries
okay so integration done let's do our
evaluation at each of the upper and
lower bounds so here comes the upper
bound so it's Q to my median its cubed
and that's divided by 3 and then I've
got 4 lots of q2 and then I subtract my
lower boundary and because the lower
boundary is 0 and I noticed that it's
going to get substituted into both of
these X terms here
I know I end up with 0 so I'm just gonna
write take away 0 along the end there
will tidy up the right-hand side it's 13
on 6 and when I have a look at this
whole line here this fractions which I
sort of instinctively want to get rid of
so I'm looking at this 6 and this 3 over
here if I multiply through by 6 that
should give it all my fractions so let's
do that
I'm gonna end up with 2 lots of q2 cubed
I'm ultimately most 6 so that leaves me
24 lots of q2 and then here I multiply
by 6 so it gets rid of that denominator
there all right so this leaves me with
this equation and what I'm trying to do
is make Q to the media and we're trying
to make that the subject except I've
kind of run into a snag because at this
point I've been handed or I've created
and generated a an equation I can't
solve at least not by hand
it's not a quadratic you can see that
the power here is three so I can't use
the quadratic formula on it and I kind
of think well there's no easy way like I
can't factorize out q2 or something like
that so there's not going to be a simple
way to find a factor for this that will
give me the solution if you if you're an
extension one student from the past you
could use something called Newton's
method which helps us approximate
solutions to equations like this but I'd
rather not do that because not within
the course that I'm teaching and you're
studying right now so how can we work
with this and the answer is with
technology essentially what I'm trying
to do here is I'm trying to solve the
equation 2x cubed plus 24x minus 13
equals 0 I've just written it with X's
instead of that awkward q2 median
notation and technology can help me with
this right this is a graph and I want to
find where does that graph equal 0 in
other words where is the x-intercept
right so you've got a whole bunch of
different pieces of software that can
help you do this for me my go-to is a
desmos so I can graph this equation here
and find where it equals 0 find its
x-intercept right so let's have a go I'm
going to write in 24
oh sorry that's that's the other
coefficient I'm gonna write 2x cubed now
I'm gonna write 24x and then I'm gonna
say minus 13 okay so this looks a bit
weird the scale is not very helpful to
us so if I just sort of pinch in I'm
going to get there you go that's the
familiar sort of cubic looking shape
that I would expect from something like
2x cubed etc and what I'm looking for if
you recall is when does this graph equal
0 so I'm going to be zooming in to find
where is that intercept and you can see
one of the things that desmos does is it
actually will highlight for you if you
click on the graph you can see that
little gray circle there is the
intercept and if I click on it I get a
coordinate so it's 0.5 to 93 and then
the other part is the zero that I'm
equal to so what I can say here is that
this is the this is the value for the
median that I'm searching for
q2 is approximately zero point five two
nine three so if I have a think about it
this does make sense because zero point
five two nine three it is around the
center of my where my probability
density function is defined between
naught and one in fact it's so close to
the middle I'm kind of suspicious so
what I'm gonna do quickly here is hide
my my equation and the cubic equation I
was looking at here if i graph my
probability density function 3 on 13 and
I'm gonna put in x squared plus 4 and
I'm only interested in a certain domain
namely from naught to 1 so you can see
here now in a zoom immune the reason why
we've got something so close to like
literally the middle between 0 & 1 0.5
the reason why we got so close is
because when you have a look at this
probability density function it's not a
uniform probability distribution but
it's very close to 1 like you can see
the interval that I'm interested in it's
it's very close to flat so that's why
you can see it's just a little bit to
the right because if you think about the
way this data is skewed probability
towards the right towards the value of 1
is higher so that means there must be
more scores on that side so in summary
when you get a question like this
particularly when you get to the point
where integration which is up here
integration is finished you substituted
everything in and I'll just make this
with bigger again so you can see more
clearly you substituted everything in
and then you get this equation and when
you tidy it up you get something which
it doesn't look like you can factorize
and you think I don't have techniques to
solve this that is where you're going to
need to appeal to technology and if you
use it appropriately if you can
translate your problem into one that the
technology can read then as you can see
it's going to be able to give you an
answer there we go there's the domain
was interesting it will give you an
answer that you can interpret and
recognize